لنبدأ بهذه الأخبار من
المملكة المتحدة.
أهمية منح تلك الدولة
الموافقة على الاستخدام الطارئ للقاح شركة فايزر
، والأهمية لماذا هم
قبل أسبوع من الولايات المتحدة
هو أنه حتى الإطار الصحيح
نعم أعتقد أن هذا سيكون
شيئًا  يسأل الكثير من الناس عن
ذلك ، لذا أعتقد أنه سؤال عادل للغاية ،
أعني أن البيانات أه البيانات
من شركة
pfizer قد استلمتها هذه الهيئة التنظيمية
مهرا
أه بعد يومين فقط من استلام إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
لبياناتهم ، لذا فإن الأمر يتعلق حقًا
بكيفية  هل تقوم
بتحليل هذه البيانات بسرعة ونحن
نعلم أن هذه
السلطة التنظيمية في بريطانيا
تميل عادةً إلى التحرك
بسرعة أكبر من الولايات المتحدة ،
وغالبًا ما تتم الموافقة على الأشياء في أوروبا
وعلى وجه التحديد المملكة المتحدة
بشكل أسرع مما تفعل في الولايات المتحدة
وهذا دائمًا موضوع بعض
الجدل ، إلى أي
مدى تعتمد على
بيانات الشركة الخاصة ، إلى أي مدى
تبدأ
من الصفر في تحليلك الخاص.  وتحقق من جميع الطرق ،
انظر إلى جميع البيانات الأولية بنفسك ،
لست متأكدًا من أنني كنت أتحدث إلى بعض الأشخاص في
وقت مبكر من هذا الصباح حول ما
كانت العملية بالضبط في المملكة المتحدة ولكنك تعلم
أنها عملية جيدة على ما أعتقد  إنه لأمر
جيد حقًا أنه لم تكن هناك
علامات حمراء كبيرة قفزت ،
ضع في اعتبارك أن الأشخاص الوحيدين الذين
رأوا هذه البيانات حقًا
حتى الآن هم
الشركة وهذا كل شيء عندما سمعنا
رقم 95 بالمائة
الذي نسمعه من الشركة
إذن هذا دليل
على وجود هيئة تنظيمية أخرى
للهيئة تقول ، لقد نظرنا إلى
هذا ،
نشعر بالثقة في المضي قدمًا والمضي قدمًا ،
لذا فهي خطوة
ضخمة وأعتقد أنها حقًا تلغراف
الذي سنراه  أنه في
أماكن أخرى بما في ذلك هنا
في الولايات المتحدة مع إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ولكن
أيضًا في بقية الاتحاد الأوروبي
في وقت قصير جدًا ، أعني أن الناس
قالوا بحلول منتصف هذا الشهر
أنه لا يزال يبدو كما هو على المسار الصحيح ،
فقد كان جديرًا بالملاحظة أيضًا
الذي - التي  خارج المملكة المتحدة ، لقد ذهبوا
بعيدًا ليقولوا انظروا ، هذا
التفويض يفي بالمعايير الدولية ،
حسنًا ، أعني لأن
هذا هو السؤال وهناك بالفعل
كما تعلمون لأنني كنت في مكالمة صغيرة
هذا الصباح مع عدد قليل من
الأشخاص المختلفين  هذا بالفعل
موضوع نقاش قليلاً ،
ما الذي تم قطعه في أي زوايا
ومرة أخرى لا أعتقد أنني لا أق
رح أنني لا أعتقد أن أي شخص يق
رح ذلك ولكن هذا تحرك بس
عة ومرة أخرى هل هناك زيادة
الاعتماد على بيانات الشركة إلى أي
مدى بدأت من الصفر
ولكن لا أعتقد أن أي شخص بالتأكيد
كنت أتحدث إليه هذا الصباح يشير إلى
أنها
لا تفي بالمعايير الدولية
فقط تحرك
بسرعة وربما ستكون مرة أخرى
إشارة إلى ما نحن  انظر هنا في الولايات المتحدة ،
لذا بشكل عام ،
أعتقد أن ما نراه في المملكة المتحدة هو
أخبار جيدة الآن لبقية العالم
لأنه من المحتمل أن تبدأ هذه الأنواع من الموافقات في الظهور في
جميع أنحاء المكان  ه